speaking of
uh of pink trip he made this video
joe rogan the ultimate nice guy
thoughts are almost like messages we
send out into the universe
to just let somebody else know they're
not alone and maybe they grab them
through some way
through some realm or portal
what's the matter rice
what is this a
yoga class it's a it's a realm or a
portal dude
thoughts are just things that we put out
of the universe man and
thoughts and portals bro
this [ __ ] idiot
she's smart dude who is this there's
jessie may paluso
what does she do besides have sex with
joe rose allegedly i don't know if
that's true
no allegedly i said i don't know if
that's true dude come on
she's not a dude um
she's she's not eddie bravo yeah come on
she uh
she's the the um
big time comedian big hit comedian okay
i don't know i don't know who this is
sorry
send out into the universe to just let
somebody else know they're not
alone and maybe they grab them through
some way it's through some
realm or portal that's very deep i i
feel like i can get deep here with you
joe and you won't judge me
i'm a he's also a dummy very
hopeful person you're sweet no you are
huh weird vibes right very weird vibes
get some weird vibes here i'm getting
some very odd vibes here
you're really well balanced
[Music]
the music is great take those pills i
gave you stupid you need pills
you made me smoke the blind i did not
say that
chill the [ __ ] out a bit what was that
an invasion of demons
demon sharks
[Music]
some people get the full wrath of satan
himself it's really scary
probably one of the the most disturbing
things you can experience
i'm a legit maniac and you could get bit
[Music]
just give me a little rub and tuck real
quick that's such an abusive of power
[Laughter]
this is amazing pink trip this might be
one of your best videos ever
they've been just getting better and
better
just a hoe i don't even know what you
just said to me
it only lasts 20 minutes you got to get
your [ __ ] together you're going to
[ __ ] die
[Music]
can we not do that shut the [ __ ] up
i will [ __ ] come over there and
strangle you to death
jamie help
that's the best part jamie help
no some shit's about to go down [ __ ]
talk to him bro
i'm sorry [ __ ] oh my god we're fighting
to the deaf
[Music]
oh man imagine the feeling when i
strangle you to death
outside like you're not going anywhere
and we're
watching you
that's so stupid
there it is bravo pink trip very good
work
i love it i love it that was
[ __ ] amazing yeah his shit's been
getting even
better